now at the beginning of your career is
it true that you had to face one of your
biggest fears actually take a look i'll
show you what one of your biggest fears
i know i earned my paycheck that day
like that is crazy
on my face
actually um we would love uh to reunite
you with your co-star if that's okay oh
uh rosie is here actually yes rosie
would you please come on out
i don't know how to react this is a jet
oh oh okay
now
i do not know you're going to bring up i
just have to say i did not know this was
going to happen this is like crazy
oh if i can open this
oh my god okay so
now um i found out a few fun facts about
rosie um she's single
okay
um
she's eight years old
okay um
and um
she loves spider-man oh
okay
but hates itsy bitsy spider okay it
doesn't like
irritated by it gets in a real cross
mood and most people often typecast
tarantulas to be dangerous although they
do produce venom
they're not really dangerous to humans
um
so
oh but i have to tell you something
hold on now that she's moving look how
gentle it is
wait a minute why why am i feeling
emotional about the tarantula
it seems sweet
you know that they can also jump like 20
feet
did you know that
it properly
caffeinated do you want to hold her well
i don't know i
i don't know
is it
is it allowed no i don't
are you gonna take her out
[Music]
do you want to tell us about central
park your new show central park is an
animated musical comedy on apple tv plus
you can catch it streaming it's about a
family that's raised a family that's
raising their kids in central park i
have to tell you i think this is a show
like that is so for me and my daughters
i'm obsessed
right you know what we're watching right
now you are calm around it oh you're
holding it do you know what we're
watching right now ellie we're watching
the office are you actually we are
watching the office is this therapy are
you like i feel like this is this has
got it's like equine is that what it is
up with
oh
i don't like it but i'm doing it okay i
will tell you i feel cured of my fear
you do i really do i mean i do know that
she is not in the wild nor full of venom
so the fact that somehow at work it
makes it okay whereas in nature in the
wild i don't i would never dare do that
i see what you're saying okay but it's
wait
hold on
they said that that sheet of paper said
yes venom or no venom
they have venom but they're not
dangerous to humans okay just a little
bit of venom okay um and
and no sudden movements i just heard in
my ear okay
i
did not know that um well
thank you rosie rosie thank you um thank
you rosie ellie
do you think that we can always just
have fun on this show and keep doing
weird cool things together like the last
time you were here we performed your
school my school pla my my well it was
an at-home um production of
a okay it was a christmas play as long
as we move slowly and gracefully
memo
so we're going to show your christmas
play that we did a reading of on digital
so you'll have to go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com and our social
channels to watch it but definitely
watch new episodes of the fantastic show
central park which by the way i mean
catherine hahn josh gad oh just an
extraordinary crew itis burgess debbie
diggs leslie odom jr it's a fantastic
show the cast alone is crazy you have
calmed me down by watching you did i
begin to feel calmer around the
tarantula because you were you took it
like
you know what you did life threw this
tarantula at you and you just dealt with
it and you did it very calmly so thank
you for for imparting that to me
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
okay is it coming do you mean now i'm
panicking okay all right thank you ellie
kemper thank you i went upside down and
it wouldn't come off okay do we need the
wrangler
so new edge episodes of central park are
available fridays on apple tv plus is
rosie upset oh rosie is just fine oh
that's so great
[Applause]
thank you thank you so much ladies and
gentlemen rosie
[Applause]
[Music]